so I recently just started a new job um
I'm not making too much money just about
I think I'm making 1350 okay um I
started two weeks ago and I was you know
kind of searching for other jobs too and
I got another job offer that offered me
$18 okay um the thing is is that my
boyfriend is completely unsupportive
about me moving to this other job and
what's the new job it would be in a
factory um doing Pete prep okay and why
is he unsupportive of
that um he is I think he has a lot of
history of other people cheating on him
this new job would be working mainly
with not men but all that fact that he's
putting all of that on you and it's
completely out of jealousy and
insecurity Kylie that's a red that's
that's a problem there are more red
flags here than at the red flag Factory
like where they make red flags